ich liebte verena und leon also das ging
ja noch eine ganze weile und ich war
ganz verliebt in diese geschichte und
ich liebe auch daniel fehlow also jetzt
nicht so aber ich habe ihn auch
menschlich sehr und wir hatten immer
ganz viel spaß und eine rechtlich
lustige zeit das war sehr besonders
er galt ja auch immer so ich kann mich
noch erinnern als der größte
frauenschwarm überhaupt jemals
mitgespielt hat ist er das auch für euch
ich frage diesmal die mädels oder wer
ist euer persönlicher favorit also
damals habe ich noch gedacht auch sonne
so eine geschichte mit mit raul richter
die schon noch gerne spielen sondern
dazu kam es nicht
die geheimen wünsche der susan
sideropoulos wir sind bei dir aus ja nee
also früher habe ich ja schon gesagt
hast du dann ist hier doch ganz so im
kurs bei mir und jetzt bin ich
tatsächlich sehr zufrieden mit dem was
ich jetzt habe ich schwer mit timo lkw
auch ein hübscher kerl kann man beklagen
[Musik]